that song yesterday i just want to point
that out i'm pretty sure
yeah america is suffering from major
cyber attacks and national security
experts say hackers
are just getting started a key pipeline
and a major meat supplier were targeted
in less than a month
and now a cyber criminal could mess with
your commute new york city's transit
authority just reported a breach
that happened back in april the white
house in some cases seems
to be downplaying the cyber threat
i would say these are private sector
entities who have a responsibility to
put in place measures to protect their
own cyber security
as it relates to why criminal actors are
taking actions against private sector
entities
i don't think i'm the right one to speak
to that total coincidence
i think you could certainly go track
down those uh cyber criminals in russia
and
have a good chat with them she's so
sarcastic about some very serious issues
that reminds me of you jessica so i have
a theory
the reason why the biden administration
is downplaying these
assaults is because they're busy up
playing
a word that i just invented right now
you're welcome america
they're up playing other issues for
example the climate crisis
should take up 50 of your attention and
then the remaining 50
goes to evil white armies of caucasian
supremacy
so you cannot worry about this cyber
stuff because your brain is filled with
evil white men
and um and windmills that's my theory
i'm sticking to it jessica you had ten
seconds to respond
do you remember on red eye that game
where you could just
push the button and liberal only got to
talk for seven seconds yes
basically
no you can't borrow that uh so i
disagree
yes and i'm sticking to my story uh we
were actually talking the green room
before this that leon panetta
was the defense secretary in the obama
biden administration was on with neil
cavuto in the last hour time of this
because
he was screaming this from the
proverbial rooftops he gave a big speech
on the intrepid
i believe in 2012 where he talked about
how warfare
is now going to be fought on the cyber
front and i believe it was something
that obama and biden
took seriously obviously our election
security is something front and center
for all of us um but i don't think that
they're downplaying it i think that
they're working as hard as they can
alongside the pentagon
to make sure that we stop having these
breaches that are affecting you know
everybody
uh from main street up to big
corporations to government hacks at this
point and we know
china and russia if they're going to get
us that's how they're going to do it but
they you know
she said it's a private sector issue
basically she just respects the private
sector
but that doesn't mean they're not
working together remember like with
apple and opening up the san bernardino
killer's phone the public face of it was
it's a private sector problem but they
were like excuse me open this phone
and then we got on the phone we don't
have phones like that anymore jessica
the liberals do
okay so evil shannon bream
um they're targeting they're targeting
our commute i mean that's that's pretty
serious because
no one wants to get stuck on a subway
when it shuts down imagine what that's
like like imagine if you're stuck in a
new york city subway train you're dead
you're dead yeah you don't want that
during summertime which is the last time
i got stuck in there at approximately 4
000 degrees celsius
and it smells like dead rats and spotty
stuff it's not good
um i found down a rabbit hole reading
about this stuff i was reading about a
guy
who was one of a handful of people who
is a ransomware negotiator and he talked
about
this is a much bigger problem than you
realize he says it happens to small and
mid-sized companies
all the time he's called in to talk with
them and you know the fbi
the government tells these private
companies you can't negotiate because
it's only going to encourage the
behavior
he's like what do you tell a hospital or
a school like you can't give chemo
treatments today because you can't
negotiate with these guys
and he said it's actually been
franchised so there are people that have
a script now
who are franchised out by these big
crime syndicates who say
this is what you say in the first offer
this is how much money i want this is
how
i mean it is absolutely insane how much
it's happening we only hear about this
stuff like
the gas pipelines and the beef don't
mess with the chicken because if the
chick-fil-a gets involved
but do you know what you're talking
about the only way americans are going
to care about this
a lot jesse is if their private
information
is blackmailed if somebody gets all of
your emails are all of or all of those
photos up on the cloud jesse
that you thought no one could see and
imagine imagine if it's if it's one to
one and one of these
free agents goes to you and says like 10
grand
or 30 grand or we drop this stuff that
that's not just a plausibility that's
gonna happen if this is happening that's
gonna happen right
yeah i mean hunter's stuff's already out
there and they said that was fake news
yeah good thing biden's working so hard
jessica actually he's not he took the
day off
he took the day off it was jill's but
that's the first lady's birthday okay
it's thursday he's the president day off
for my birthday
yeah i mean i don't even take thursdays
off he's riding bikes in delaware people
are hacking us
to bits and pieces he doesn't even know
there's a cyber war
they hacked hillary's campaign manager
and the democrats wanted to restart
world war three now they had big beef
and big oil
and gensake says it's the private sector
they can fight the war
private sectors here in america it's on
the homeland
i mean you're basically telling the
terrorists these are targets the
president's not
what if they bombed a business is that
what it's private sector business yeah i
mean do they have to go after whole
foods for the democrats
to care they actually went after the
ferry to martha's vineyard
yes the next what are they going to do
the hampton jitney oh god god no
express democrats don't have anywhere
anywhere to go after that
so but i said this yesterday they have
to bring back the bush doctrine
which says right now they're not
operating without the tacit approval of
the kremlin in russia
so you hold putin accountable that's how
you do it biden's going to go over to
switzerland and sit down with vladimir
at the summit
and he's going to say knock it off
they're going to release a readout that
says
biden says putin knock it off and then
cnn's going to say
biden's so tough on russia no biden has
to do something to russia to make russia
feel pain
so they don't do it again until he does
that they're going to keep packing
so on the business side of this are
there companies out there that could
make
that like in the private sector that can
prevent these things from happening
where are do do they exist that have
backups for these companies in case
they're
compromised or yes and you saw how with
the mta
here in new york city how quickly that
hack was resolved
part of the problem is and it is on the
private sector they spend
money on technology that can yield a
profit
they don't necessarily over his
throughout his
modern history spent money on something
that they can't
quantify not worth it today net income
on the other end which is safety but to
jesse's point
this is joe biden's opportunity to be a
badass
right all he has to do is come out and
just get i wrote a little a tiny little
speech for him
if you attack the united states and any
vital infrastructure or
services there is no safe place on this
planet for you
we will come for you and we will kill
you if you're
a pipeline air traffic control
doesn't matter if a nation is behind the
cyber crime we will treat you
as if this is an act of war if it's an
individual we will treat you
as a terrorist there is nowhere to hide
on this earth
he could call it the biden doctrine but
he's busy
eating cake and hiding somewhere in the
white house
you know if uh if these hackers were
only white supremacists
we would already be on top of this stuff
ahead hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else